for ryan in the scene where you were
kissing the girl was that real
whoa
blake is really throwing her voice
honey
what the [ __ ] ryan reynolds is
definitely sitting in the hot seat
during a q a for the actor's latest
netflix film the atom project a young
fan asks ryan about his co-star love
interest in the film played by zoe
saldana specifically this scene
i found you
you found me
in the scene where you were kissing the
girl was that real
whoa
this is the best q a ever is the
greatest q a yeah ryan's other co-star
jennifer garner couldn't help but tease
him as he continued to struggle with a
response i guess it was kinda
kinda real but um
how do i answer this is this being
broadcast everywhere too um
i didn't mean it
then the canadian actor who's married to
blake lively reveals he has a hard time
talking to their kids about what's real
versus what's happening in a movie this
is the thing i don't know how to explain
this to my own kids
like they watch this and like daddy what
are you doing like it's like exactly the
tactic i would use on them not anger but
just disappointment
yeah
great question though
he exits that way
ryan shared a similar sentiment with e.t
back in 2013 before he had kids but it
was a fear that had to do with his
animated roles let's go people pick it
up i don't know if this is a blessing or
a curse because when i have kids they're
going to want to watch the anime i'm
going to hear my voice in the house over
and over again on repeat for about four
or five years fast forward to 2022 blake
and ryan have three daughters together
betty james and inez and one thing's for
sure the detective pikachu star's family
supports his career through and through
that's blake and ryan looking stunning
at the atom project premiere last month
and when e.t caught up with the leading
man he gave a glimpse of what life is
like at home with his girls are you that
kind of dad he wants the girls to like
have good behavior make all the good
grades really think about your future
right now well i mean i think i would be
a
psychotic if i didn't want my children
to at least you know
try to do something you know right and
with integrity um you know focused a
little bit more on that i think then
you know my kids are seven five and two
i'm not like you gotta get better grades
i mean
i'm like i don't it doesn't matter you
pee yeah you know you're gonna hate it
yeah exactly no i'm just happy if they
finish a bowl of cereal
what is yours in blake's parental style
like uh i don't know i would say
probably like a brown belt at this point
i don't know
work working up the chain of command up
next a collaboration blake and ryan will
be stepping away from their kiddos for
one night in may the metropolitan museum
of art in new york city announced the
two as co-chairs for the upcoming met
gala alongside regina king and
lin-manuel miranda it's it's like the
real life fairy tale ball that you get
every every year hopefully after the
event the proud parents won't have much
explaining to do
[Music]